jeffrey toobin is suspended from the new
yorker after an unfortunate zoom call
incident the media continued to refuse
to ask serious questions about hunter
biden's emails
and trump goes to war with anthony fauci
over kovitz strategy i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
protect it at expressvpn.com
ben okay before we get started quick
reminder let me just tell you something
that you should try you should
definitely do it so my wife and i
we got this amazing hand-painted
portrait of our family we got it a
couple of years ago it was before
the newest baby well now we have another
baby and we plan on heading right on
back to paintyourlife.com
this is where you can get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo
at a truly affordable price you send any
picture yourself your kids family a
special place cherished pet
or you can combine photos into one
painting with paint your life's
compilation portraits you can actually
bring together family members who have
never had the chance to meet or create a
portrait of the entire family
without the need for everyone to be
there for a family photo you choose from
a team of world-class artists and you
work with them until every
detail is perfect you can order a
custom-made hand-painted portrait
in less than five minutes it's
meaningful it's personal it can be
cherished forever we have one hanging
on our wall right now it really is
spectacular when they brought us back to
first version we had some quibbles and
so we told them to fix it they did
they kept fixing it until they got it
right at paintyourlife.com there is no
risk if you don't love that final
painting the money is refunded
guaranteed
right now is limited time offer get 20
off your painting that is correct 20
off and free shipping to get the special
offer text the word ben to 64 000 that
is ben
to 64 000 text ben to 64 000 paint your
life
celebrate the moments that matter most
okay so
last night something strange happened
over at the new yorker
so it is not supremely shocking that
jeffrey toobin
just got caught pleasuring himself on a
new yorker
zoom call i mean so a couple of things
one everybody understands that zoom
calls generally
are uh are a waste of time so so
i think we can all take it that
metaphorically they are masturbatory
and useless but jeffrey toobin took that
extremely extremely literally
jeffrey toobin apparently has now been
suspended for masturbating on a zoom
video call between members of the new
yorker and wnyc radio last week
toobin says he did not realize his video
was on well i would imagine i mean
i can't imagine that he was like boop
video odd all right go to town on
yourself
he said i made an embarrassingly stupid
mistake believing i was off camera i
apologize to my wife family friends and
co-workers
i believed i was not visible on zoom i
thought no one on the zoom call could
see me
i thought i had muted the zoom video he
added
apparently two people who were on the
call told vice separately the call was
an election simulation
oh god featuring many of the new yorkers
biggest stars
jane mayer was playing establishment
republican so it turns out that the most
perverse pornographic thing
about this actual event is that jane
mayer the reporter
who has been putting out like brett
kavanaugh fan fiction
was playing the establishment
republicans evan osnos was joe biden
jelani cobb was establishment democrats
which is hilarious
masha gessen played donald trump andrew
marantz was the far right too halpern
was left-wing democrats dexter filkins
was the military and jeffrey toobin
played the court well it turns out the
court
was in session but motion motion to
withdraw
denied
both people who spoke on the condition
of anonymity in order to speak freely
noted it was unclear how much each
person saw both said that they saw two
been going to town
the two sources described a juncture in
the election as a simulation where there
was a strategy session the democrats and
republicans went into their respective
break rooms for about 10 minutes at this
point
it seemed like tuban was on a second
video call
the sources said that when the groups
returned from their breakout rooms tubin
lowered the camera the people on the
call said they could see
two been um tubing then tubin
left the call moments later he called
back in seemingly unaware of what his
colleagues have been able to see and a
simulation
continued hilariously the new yorker
says that jeffrey tubin has been
suspended while we investigate the
matter so let's just be clear about this
first of all
if he has been suspended he's not going
to be gone for schlong
but beyond that jeffrey toobin i mean if
this guy is on the right how fast is he
fired how fast is he fired and gone
forever right you don't just get to pull
it out
and uh and enjoy yourself i mean i
understand that this is what members of
the media do in front of cameras all the
time
and the good news for jim acosta who is
a fellow anchor at cnn is that finally
we've discovered a cnn anchor who loves
himself more than jim acosta loves jim
acosta
with that said not a great look for
jeffrey tube and yes am i enjoying this
story too much of course i am but
frankly jeffrey toobin of all the human
beings on earth sort of deserves this
considering that
you know years back he uh sort of
knocked up
a woman who was a the daughter of a
family friend and uh and then pressured
her to have an abortion so
he's a delight he's just he's a
delightful person jeffrey toobin
so farewell to jeffrey toobin at least
for now his refractory period has yet to
be established by the new yorker
so that that is where we are now i think
that there is a a metaphor here
for the media's coverage of everything
which is that it is all about
self-pleasure it is not about pleasing
the american public
the american public does not go first in
the world of the media instead
it is just the media pleasuring itself
all the media care about
is making themselves happy and what that
means is pretending to be objective
while simultaneously ignoring stories
they don't want to be out there
and this brings us to the hunter biden
story so the fact is
that the huh you didn't think i was
going to make that connection did you
didn't
you didn't see how i was going to go
there did you but it happened that's
right
we are professionals at segways here on
ben shapiro show
it is incredible how the media's desire
to pleasure itself at the expense of the
american public means
they will simply ignore stories that
they do not like or mischaracterize
those stories with no evidence
at all so the new york post of course
has reported over the last couple of
weeks
that hunter biden's emails have now been
made somewhat public
apparently he dropped off his laptops
allegedly with a delaware computer
salesperson computer fixer
and and then just left them there
because he's a derelict is sort of the
allegation
fox news now has gotten a hold of
documents showing that hunter biden did
in fact sign
for the computers when he left them at
this repair shop in 2019
and one of those emails show well among
other things they show that
he had emailed with ukrainian oligarch
who said that hunter had brokered
a a meeting between joe and this
ukrainian oligarch the biden campaign
originally denied them they said well
maybe that maybe a meeting happened
then there was a set of two emails that
really were even worse
for joe biden one was hunter biden
talking
with a chinese company and in the midst
of that conversation on which several
people were copied
there was a mention that 20 of some sort
of
of some sort of deal would go to hunter
biden with 10
held in escrow for the big guy fox news
has reported according to one of their
unnamed sources that the big guy refers
to joe biden so in other words joe biden
may have been directly benefiting from
hunter
jet setting around the world and doing
these deals which would uh cast a
different
light on the entire situation it is one
thing if joe biden do nothing
it's another thing if joe biden knew
something and was willing to let his son
traffic off of his name to make money
it is a third thing altogether if joe
biden not only knew but was actively
involved in taking money
for all of this that now verges on on
the criminal
now joe biden has steadfastly refused to
answer any questions about this
and the media steadfastly refused to ask
serious questions or follow-up questions
on any of this they'll ask the
occasional question and they let it go
so the media have come up with an
alternative theory see here's what the
media are afraid of the media are afraid
of
is that they do the same thing they did
in 2016. namely they accurately report
the hillary clinton email thing
and then two weeks before the election
there's the james comey letter and
hillary clinton loses what the media are
desperately afraid of
is that they start actually reporting on
the hunter biden story and joe biden's
lead dissipates and now members of the
media are responsible
for joe biden not being president of the
united states the media got off
scot-free last time so the media
they've internalized the fact that they
sort of were responsible for donald
trump's election a little bit but they
tried to blame it alternatively on
social media they tried to blame it on
facebook they tried to blame it
on the russians well now they are trying
to preemptively blame
an email scandal on the russians this is
their new answer they're saying we're
not even going to report on this because
this
is the rooskies the russians are hiding
under their bed the russian dressing in
their fridge
was actually created by russia because
the russians are hiding inside the house
after all the alarm systems are set it's
too late it's just like cape fear
the russians are actually hiding inside
the house dressed as the maid no matter
what
the russians are behind everything
andrea mitchell at nbc news
she said you know i think this is a
russian plot now again
notice not a single aspect of the story
has yet to be debunked or even remarked
upon by the biden campaign
and yet nbc anchors are saying overtly
this is russian propaganda despite the
fact like
you have to make a claim either this is
russian disinformation in which case
it's all false
or all the emails are real and being
misconstrued
but you can't have it both ways here's
andrew mitchell claiming that it's all
russian disinformation there are new
questions about an
unverified report targeting joe biden's
son
and new reporting about possible ties to
a russian disinformation effort aimed at
influencing the u.s election
nbc senior washington correspondent
andrea mitchell has details on this
hey andrea good morning hi there hoda
nbc news has confirmed
that u.s spy agencies have gathered
intelligence that the president's
personal lawyer rudy giuliani
was dealing with alleged russian
intelligence agents last year
on a trip to ukraine as part of his
effort to dig up dirt on joe biden
okay that is nothing new okay that
seriously we've known this for a while
is that
rudy giuliani was hanging out in ukraine
and was speaking to people who may or
may not have been russian agents russia
rudy himself has acknowledged this but
that does not mean that the email
scandal has to do with russia in fact as
you will see
the director of national intelligence
john ratcliffe overtly denied this
yesterday and said there's no
intelligence information to support this
allegation
put forward by the media but the media
are not in the business of conveying
information to you they're in the
business of self-pleasure jeffrey
jeffrey toobin's style they're
journalism all over the place we'll get
to more of this in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that hiring can be
incredibly incredibly complicated let's
say that you have a producer and she is
really with it you know she's on top of
things
she's i would say really diligent at her
work let's call her rebecca
and let's say that as soon as you go to
south florida in order to establish
residency and get ready for the move and
all of this that rebecca somehow
goes off the rails a little bit and
rebecca finds herself at a house party
where people have been murdered and you
think to yourself well
rebecca and really nice catholic girl
uh you may have made some choices here
and those choices may have let us down a
dark
dark south florida path at that point
you may look at zip recruiter
what if instead of just randomly waiting
for resumes to come in you went to zip
recruiter
okay whether you've already voted
whether you still need to vote it's our
country's chance to choose great
candidates
there are a lot of jobs to fill
ziprecruiter helps you fill the jobs at
your company right now you can try it
for free
at ziprecruiter.com dailywire when you
post the job on zip recruiter it gets
sent
out to over 100 job sites with just one
click then zip recruiter's powerful
matching technology finds people with
the right skills and experience for your
job
and actively invites them to apply so
you get qualified candidates fast
it's no wonder four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candidate within
the very first day right now you can try
zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
you may be stressed out about everything
going on around you it's a pretty
stressful world but you won't be
stressed about hiring when you try zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire certainly rebecca should know
better than to
hang out in south beach with the
derelict as soon as moving from
as soon as she moved from l.a but you
know that's how you find yourself in a
zip recruiter ad zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest way to hire go check them
out right now
at supercrew.com dailywire okay so
politico also picks up on this this
nonsense
report that russian disinformation is
responsible for the hundred byte emails
now again disinformation is the
suggestion that false information is
being put out by the russian government
in order to see the american public
that's what disinformation means
okay it does not mean that there that
the russians are trafficking in good
information
disinformation is like a kgb tactic it's
where you put out information that is
overtly false
in order to confuse people that is not
what is happening here
and you can say that maybe the russians
distributed the infra like russian
disinformation good example the steele
dossier is russian disinformation
there's nothing in the steele dossier
that came from the russians that has
actually been confirmed as of yet and
there's plenty of stuff that is overtly
false
nothing in the hunter biden email
scandal has been even remarked upon by
the biden campaign or accused of being
false
and yet you have this article from
politico more than 50 former senior
intelligence officials have signed on to
a letter outlining their belief that the
recent disclosure of emails allegedly
belonging to joe biden's son has quote
all the classic earmarks of a russian
information operation
well you know if they're speculating
without any inside information that this
looks like the russians
must be the russians i guess that's the
way this works now is that open
speculation
is now taken extremely seriously so long
as it cuts in favor of joe biden
now there's only one problem the
director of national intelligence john
ratcliffe he said openly yesterday we
have no evidence this is a russian
disinformation
campaign and again there are now
receipts with fox news
that hunter biden apparently dropped off
this computer to delaware computer
repair shop
here is john ratcliffe director of
national intelligence denying the
self-pleasuring media's narrative that
this is all russian disinformation
it is adam schiff the chairman of the
house intelligence
committee who as you pointed out on
friday said that the intelligence
community believes
that hunter biden's laptop and the
emails on it are part of some russian
disinformation campaign let me be clear
the intelligence community doesn't
believe that because there's no
intelligence that supports that
and we have shared no intelligence with
chairman schiff or any other member of
congress
that hunter biden's laptop is part of
some russian disinformation campaign
it's simply not true
it doesn't matter adam schiff was
pushing that story politico was pushing
that story andrea mitchell was pushing
that story because they're all on the
same side they're all on the same side
see when i say that the media are
self-pleasuring what i mean
is that they are all democrats and they
want c joe biden win and they are very
upset at the possibility that they would
contribute to joe biden losing and so
they've become the overt policy
the overt communications arm of the
democratic national committee and of joe
biden's campaign
personally i mean how bad is this the
biden campaign can't even acknowledge
that like they're they're saying that
it's russian disinformation or that
it was a hacking job or whatever it is a
biden spokeswoman named jenna arnold
was on fox news and would not say that
the emails were inauthentic so we keep
hearing that the emails
somehow are a lie or that all of it's
not true
she wouldn't even claim that they were
inauthentic so what exactly is their
case
is the case that the emails are put out
there by the russians because we have no
evidence of that
is the case that the emails are fake we
keep hearing that we keep hearing that
this is
quote unquote fake news that the
metadata don't match or something like
that
but nobody from the biden campaign is
even willing to say that the emails are
fake because apparently they're not fake
right the emails are not fake which
means that at some point you actually
have to answer the question
as to whether joe biden is very easy
honestly this is very easy for the biden
campaign to kill the story
all they have to do is say at no point
has joe biden ever received money
or had money held in trust for him by
hunter biden
that's all he has to say why won't he
just say that that's two sentences long
and why won't the media just badger him
to say i mean he did a full on town hall
last week
and george stephanopoulos did not ask
him one question about this topic even
though it was the hottest topic in the
country
social media still have suspended the
new york post for even having tweeted
the article
twitter still has the new york post
account locked out
so you've got overt liars like aaron
rupar over at vox who literally just
cuts clips out of context puts them out
there and then pretends
that his little paraphrases are accurate
how i mean so badly
that yesterday even the left-wing media
people like daniel dale at cnn were
fact-checking aaron rupar
his account is fine but the new york
post account again
have they even explained what is false
about the original new york post story
yet
the answer of course is no here is joe
biden's campaign spokeswoman say
admitting that no one says the emails
are inauthentic
so much of this is unconfirmed okay okay
so jenna jenner it's real simple you say
it's unconfirmed tell us what parts
are not true hunter biden knows what
emails he has and hasn't sent
are you saying in the campaign saying
that these emails aren't his
it's unclear to me can anyone say that
these emails are inauthentic and so far
i haven't heard anybody say that
yeah i think that's fair i don't think
anybody's saying okay
let me just let me ask you about okay so
she says i've never heard anybody say
that the emails are inauthentic
so then when you keep saying that it's
unconfirmed you just kind of confirmed
it right there
just confirmed the emails are real so
what exactly is unconfirmed they keep
saying unconfirmed
unconfirmed just means that you don't
know the original source of the story
okay but actually in this case you kind
of do know the original source of the
story since fox news has the receipt
as to the as to the laptops being sent
to this this guy in delaware in fact we
know much more about the story than we
know about most of the stories that the
mainstream media puts out
through their anonymous sourcing and yet
the media refused to cover this thing
straight
they refused to cover it they refused to
ask the biden campaign questions
and this of course has pissed trump off
to no end and he is absolutely right i
mean
honestly he is right to say that the
media are botching the story
so trump said yesterday that biden is
going to stay in his basement he will
stay in his basement he declared a
quote-unquote lid again
okay a lid means that he's going to stay
in his basement he declared a lid until
thursday
yesterday was monday we are two weeks
from an election
and he declared he is going to literally
hide in his basement and watch
cocoon on loop until the debate
here is here is trump going after biden
for it
they put the lid on it to every day you
wake up where's biden today sir uh he's
uh littered out
he's lit it out what does that mean that
means he's going to stay in the basement
all day
but i think today he's staying in the
basement to talk to his lawyers they
caught him cold
okay um you know he's not wrong about
this joe biden is in fact hiding in his
basement
for sure okay then trump went even
further and we'll get to that in just
one second because that of course
becomes the headline
the media don't want to cover what biden
is doing they want to cover what trump
is doing
biden knows this which is why he refuses
to answer simple questions like will you
pack the court
instead he says just if i answer that
question come on man if i answer that
question
you're going to focus on me you're not
gonna focus on on on white you need to
focus on
trump and he's bad and he's orange i'm
gonna go to sleep now
i need japioka pudding i'll see you
later bye guys
early bird special denny's take out too
much covet in the restaurant
catch you later and you're like okay
let's go focus on what trump is saying
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let us talk about the fact that right
now you got a lot of costs at your
business some of those costs involve the
mail but it's not just the cost of the
mail
it is also the time that you have to
take to schlep all of your stuff
over to the post office you don't need
to do any of that stuff this holiday
season more people will be mailing stuff
than ever which means the post office is
going to be busy you don't have time to
stand in line over there stamps.com
brings the post office and now ups
shipping directly to your computer you
can mail and ship anything from the
convenience of your home or office
with stamps.com anything you can do at
the post office you can do with just a
few clicks
plus stamps.com saves you money with
deep discounts you can't even get at the
post office here at dailywire we've used
stamps.com since 2017.
no more wasting our time with stamps.com
you get five cents off every first class
stamp
up to 40 off priority mail up to 62
percent off
ups shipping rates stamps.com is a
no-brainer it saves you time it saves
you money
we've been using stamps.com since 2017
here at dailywire
again because we like saving time and we
like saving money don't spend a minute
of your holiday season at the post
office this year instead
sign up for stamps.com there is no risk
with my promo code shapiro you get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus
free postage and digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage
type in shapiro that is stamps.com enter
shapiro again that is stamps.com
never go to the post office again okay
so
trump is talking about biden on the
campaign trail and he lashes out at the
bidens
he says that they are criminals which
again trump throws this term around a
lot
basically anybody that he doesn't like
or that he suspects of criminal activity
becomes a criminal like literally
everyone
and then he uses the word criminal in a
different sense right he
he says that that the media are criminal
for not covering the story
and in a colloquial sense i mean people
say that kind of stuff all the time
right you say
it's absolutely criminal that this
person didn't do x we don't actually
mean that we want them to be physically
locked up
but the media pretend to take this
incredibly literally like trump is
threatening to lock up the reporter he's
going to activate his ag
to go arrest the reporter for not asking
a question about joe biden in violation
of zero criminal statutes
right that of course is not true trump
is really loose with his language
everybody the great lie of this election
is that we have to treat every
absurdity by trump as the new low i keep
saying this and i've been saying this
for a long time
the bottom has are there there's no new
bottom for trump it's not like he says
something new
and you're like oh my god i can't
believe he's this bad everybody just
goes
all right yep that's from doing his
thing man all right
some people love it most people don't
you know i look at stuff that he says on
a daily basis and i just slap myself in
the forehead
but is it like a new low see in in order
to use the phrase new low it actually
has to be lower than he has previously
gone and you're going to have to explain
to me
how him saying that the biden should be
locked up is any different from him
saying that hillary clinton
should be locked up if if you're saying
that he says you know bad things on
route you're gonna have to explain to me
how the stuff he says in 2020 is
significantly worse than the stuff that
he said in 2015 2016 in other words
donald trump is consistently at the same
level and in order for you
to be driven to the point where you vote
for biden the media have to continue to
focus in
on every trump headline the only way to
do that is if there is new
news right it is not news that donald
trump says stupid things he says stupid
things a lot
i've been very critical of the stupid
things that he says that's not news
in the same way that it is not news that
my son is yelling again because i turned
off the tv that's not news it's just
what happens whenever i turn off the tv
donald trump he is going to yell and
scream and say things
and then the media are going to treat it
as a new low even though it's not a new
low they'll treat it as a new low
so that you are reminded of donald trump
as opposed to being reminded of the fact
that joe biden still won't answer very
simple questions
about whether or not he was involved in
some sort of corruption scheme
with his son now so one half of the
statement that trump is about to make
look a well-calibrated statement
i know this i'm just spitting in the
wind here but a well-calibrated
statement here
from trump would be something like this
there are very suspicious activities
surrounding hunter and joe biden the
media refused to answer them it's
disgusting that the media refused to
answer simple questions of my opponent
and allow him to hide in his basement
and the only questions they ask him is
about the flavor of ice cream that he's
eating
that's wrong and it's bad and it's
indicative of the evils of our modern
day media which is basically a wing of
the democratic party
right that would be the well calibrated
version the trump version is
we should lock huntry and joe up and
you're a criminal if you don't ask about
it here's trump
[Music]
he got caught read his laptop and you
know who's a criminal you're a criminal
for not reporting it
you are a criminal for not reporting it
let me tell you something
joe biden is a criminal and he's been a
criminal for a long time
and you're a criminal in the media for
not reporting it
okay so again people decided to take
this super seriously is that like even
close to a new law that's not even a low
i'm sorry that's like that's like just
normal trump right him saying that the
bidens are criminal
when there are allegations out there
about biden corruption is not a shock
and him saying reporters are criminal
for not reporting it he doesn't actually
mean
that you're going to lock up the
reporters again the only person who
tried to lock up reporters i'm aware of
was barack obama who actively attempted
to
wiretap the ap he actually went after a
fox news journalist james rosen
while he was president of the united
states i know that we memory whole the
entire obama era
but i mean the only person who
threatened the press
in my in my recent memory was barack
obama not donald trump trump says a lot
of things it was barack obama who did a
lot of things
which does bring us to a larger point
here
about the way that we are meant to
perceive joe biden's campaign by the
media
the way that we are meant to perceive
joe biden's campaign and joe biden
becoming president by the media
is that it is a return to normalcy i've
been saying for years that this would be
the biden campaign return to normalcy
and in the aftermath of a joe biden
election make no mistake that will be
the media line
kovid will suddenly recede into the
distance well now it's being well
handled
wow the world will will be back on its
moorings the right people the
responsible people
are back in charge and you're and you're
happier right i mean
joe biden isn't out there saying crazy
things every day he's not tweeting every
day we're back to normal
the lie there is that there was a normal
barack obama's administration was not
normal it was a new normal
barack obama was an incredibly divisive
president his economic plans were a
disaster
barack obama's foreign policy was even
more of a disaster than his economic
plans
the simmering social tensions of america
were kept slightly below the surface
the trump era ripped them wide open
because the left decided to burst out
through the through the hole like the
alien through john hurt's belly an alien
but it's but those tensions were there
and those tensions would still be there
if joe biden were elected they wouldn't
just go away i mean there were riots in
ferguson in 2014.
there were riots in milwaukee in 2016.
there was a mass shooting of dallas
police officers in 2016. like the idea
that that everything was hunky-dory and
beautiful and placid during the obama
era is such a media creation it's such a
lie i mean again that goes back to the
media pleasuring themselves
the same media who refused to cover the
obama administration in any sort of
depth or detail declaring that the only
scandal for the obama administration is
that obama once wore a tan suit
we'll go back to the lie but i'm not
sure that the the lie may be comforting
but it's certainly not true
which is that that we're back to normal
we're back everything is now fine
okay things will still be not great in
terms of our social
fabric and in terms of social decay if
joe biden is president of the united
states particularly if the democrats win
back the senate and you see the radicals
on the march
the lie that the media have told is that
trump
was the murderer and not the coroner
that he got into office and suddenly
things went south that is not correct
okay things were already quite south
when it came to the social fabric of the
united states had been framed for quite
a while barack obama wildly
wildly exacerbated the fraying of that
social fabric donald trump didn't put it
back together
but there's a lie that's out there which
is that everything will calm down if joe
biden is president
on the surface it will calm down because
it turns out the way that many people
consume the chaos is via the media and
the media have an interest in saying
that things have calmed down if joe
biden becomes president
but under the surface will things have
calmed down no they'll get worse because
the underlying issues
that we are addressing with politics the
underlying values divisions in the
united states are not going to be
lessened
by a biden administration they're going
to be they're going to be heightened by
a biden administration which is going to
very aggressively pursue
leftist agenda social items in
contravention of your individual rights
we'll get to more of this in just one
second because again the media are
ignoring stories they don't like in
order to promulgate a particular agenda
we'll get to that in one second first
we hear stories in the news all the time
there's a good guy he uses a gun to
protect his family from criminals and
then he is the one arrested this does
happen on a fairly regular basis
the legal system is not always fair
responsibly armed americans sometimes
become political targets
it's just not right for good responsible
americans to wind up in jail or
embroiled in a lawsuit if you have to
defend yourself
or your family in this day and age given
what's going on you do need a gun to
protect yourself
and your family well here's how you can
take a simple powerful journey to
firearms and self-defense confidence
it's called the complete concealed carry
and family defense guide from the united
states concealed carry association the
uscca it is 100 free
you will learn how to detect attackers
before they see you how to survive a
mass shooting the safest and most
dangerous places to sit in a restaurant
how to responsibly own and store a gun
even if you got little kids and a whole
lot more it's 164 pages it comes with
the bonus
audio version so you can listen whenever
you want it is very important to own a
firearm and to know how to use it
responsibly and what your legal rights
actually are just text ben to 87 222 to
get started
you will get instant access and a chance
to win 1 000 so you can buy a gun to
protect your family text ben to 87
222 right now again text ben to 87 222
right this very instant okay so again
the media
are our full are four square behind joe
biden because they're going to
promulgate the notion
that the only bad things that have ever
happened are attached to donald trump
but
donald trump did not arrive newly formed
in washington dc and then turn
washington dc into his image washington
dc was a very bad place before donald
trump ever got there the social fabric
fabric of the united states was already
rent long before donald trump
got there and if joe biden should be put
in charge the media will try to put a
lid on it
and the media will try to pretend that
that everything is bad they will
whitewash it but the rot
is still in the walls and in fact the
media whitewashing the rot in the walls
means that people are not going to
perceive as well the rot that is in the
walls when it comes to our politics
i mean joe biden has been enmeshed in
the swamp for a very long time
tim carney has a good piece over at the
washington examiner how joe biden and
his revolving door lobbyist donor aide
helped big oil profit off of burmese
oppression
he says here's something joe biden has
never explained why as chairman of the
senate foreign relations committee
divided weakened sanctions against burma
to benefit a big u.s oil company did it
have anything to do with his chief of
staff having been in the pay of that oil
company which was partnered with burma's
oppressive government
biden's big oil lobbyist and burma story
starts in 2003 when congress passed the
burmese freedom and democracy act mitch
mcconnell was the chief senate sponsor
california democrat tom lantos was the
house sponsor
congress barred imports from burma in
response to burmese human rights
violations
one of the companies lobbying on the
bill was unical a u.s oil giant since
merged with chevron
one of its lobbyists on the matter was
alan hoffman formerly biden's senate
chief of staff would soon again be biden
senate chief of staff and would in the
future
hold top jobs in the obama biden
administration unical was partnered with
burma's regime in a natural gas field
and related pipeline
and so if congress forced a full-fledged
divestment unical would lose millions in
profits
some advocates were pushing for exactly
that
and this is what hoffman and unical's
other lobbyists were hired to fight
against public records joe hoffman and
his colleagues at k street
firm timmins and company lobbied the
senate the house and the administration
on lantos's bill in the first and second
half of 2003.
they got their money's worth of teams
while the united states steadily pushed
all sorts of companies out of doing
business with burma
unical and later chevron were allowed to
keep their gas fields and pipeline
investment there splitting the profits
with the burmese regime that was
globally recognized
as a human rights abuser hoffman left k
street passed back through the revolving
door became biden's chief of staff once
more
in 2007 lantos introduced a new
legislation that would ban us investment
in burma
forcing again chevron to divest when the
house passed lantos's bill it included
such a provision then lantos died in
early 2008
biden became chairman of the senate
foreign affairs committee he passed a
version of lantos's bill that stripped
out the language
forcing chevron to divest at this time
the burmese government was getting about
half of all of its revenue from oil and
gas enterprises so once again
you know look biden is a swamp creature
he has long been a swamp creature but we
are going to go back to the new
we'll go back to the old normal of sort
of normal type corruption
if joe biden is president and we're all
supposed to be grateful for that
because the media don't wish to focus on
any of this they wish to focus in on
trump's violation of rhetorical norms
now as i've said before trump's
violation of rhetorical norms is a
violation
and much of it is really bad but that
does not get to the underlying problems
in the country
like at all in any real way which brings
us
to a separate topic and that is the the
treatment of trump and covet so the
because it turns out that trump's policy
on a fair bit of
of his kind of agenda has been quite
good right his foreign policy has been
quite good tom
president trump has not started any new
wars first president my lifetime to not
start any new wars
president trump has brokered peace in
the middle east that continues to to
bear fruit in the israel-uae
relationship saudi arabia is probably
going to join into that sometime in the
near future
trump has been very harsh on china in a
way the obama biden administration never
was
right on foreign policy trump has been
excellent on domestic policy we had the
most booming economy in half a century
under donald trump before covet hit and
so democrats have been forced to rely
on kovid as their chief point democrats
have been forced to rely on coveted as
their chief point
so i cut a video i put it out yesterday
about why i
didn't vote for trump in 2016 but i am
voting for trump in 2020 and it is
racked up over
almost 2 million views on twitter it's
racked up probably at this point over a
million views
on on youtube and people are watching it
and taking it seriously which i
appreciate because i think that it is a
fair
take on why a conservative would vote
for president trump
and one of the points that i make in
there is that all
of the trump wildness and craziness and
tweets and rhetorical excesses and
immoralities all of that is baked into
the cake already right for better or
worse that is the normal
okay and it's not as though that normal
just goes away as soon as trump is off
the scene
right the boundaries have been pushed
that was not foreclosed in 2016 and so
that is what it is
okay and not voting for him in 2020
doesn't actually change anything
along these lines it's not like we all
go back to wonderful civility the
democrats were not participating in
wonderful
civility before trump arrived on the
scene they were calling mitt romney
uh a homophobe who forcibly cut the hair
of gay kids strapped dogs to the top of
his car and was a vicious racist
so rhetorical norms have been violated
before so
democrats have decided to focus in on
covert so i cut this video and the video
does briefly talk about covid
it talks about kovid specifically with
regard to president trump
refusing to take top down control over
the entire country and essentially
assert dictatorial executive branch
control
over lockdown policy and i say that's a
very good thing because this has been
the greatest government power grab of my
lifetime
you've seen governments literally
shutting down every human activity
against the science by the way because
the who says that lockdowns are bad
policy
there are ways in which you can operate
your business safely
there there's social distancing there's
mask wearing right there are things that
you can do to continue to operate
now as i've said before trump's rhetoric
on covet has sucked right trump has said
a lot of things on covet that are not
good
trump has not been a good advocate for
his own positions but the actual actions
by the administration on covet
have been quite good they got the
ventilators where they needed to go they
got the ppe
where it needed to go they've developed
operation warp speed which will result
by the end of this year in all
probability
in a working vaccine the fastest vaccine
development in human history
right all of that is quite good and more
than that if you look at trump's policy
joe biden has no different policy
there's a point that mike pence made in
a debate with kamal harris
the covet policy pursued by the trump
administration is identical
to the coveted strategy that kamala
harris and joe biden say they will
pursue
with one exception joe biden says that
he will call people up and tell them to
wear masks which of course makes no
difference at all
it also happens to be true that no one
has a good handle on kobet
basically in countries where covert was
widely seated
it has moved quickly across the entire
country right now europe is seeing more
of a spread than the united states is
that donald trump's fault i wasn't i
wasn't aware that donald trump was
president of belgium
i wasn't aware that he was president of
france or that he was prime minister of
the uk
i wasn't aware of any of that because he
isn't right that is just a simple fact
no one has a good handle on covet and
yet democrats have created this
alternative
mental structure the entire media have
bought into which is that donald trump's
behavior on kovid is singularly
disqualifying they've bought into the
lie that if donald trump weren't
president
two hundred thousand americans would be
alive right now there is no evidence
this is the case whatsoever
even with regard to trump's
foolishnesses about
public gatherings right trump has
basically gone out there he's in public
gatherings people wear masks he was
there was a super spreader event at the
white house right that's bad i said at
the time that's bad i disagree with all
of that
i think it's political malpractice it
also happens to be true the entire
democratic party said you could go out
and party in the streets
millions strong if you just shouted
george floyd's name without a mask
and that magically this woke virus would
not affect you
so the notion that democrats were going
to handle this thing on a practical
level
any differently than republicans did is
just a lie but there's been a narrative
created so people said about my video
why didn't you focus in on trump's
coveted policy and i said because i
don't think
that trump's coveted policy is a point
of differentiation between democrats and
republicans
i don't see the magic bullet that
democrats would use that trump
has not attempted i see ways in which
trump could have spoken differently
and better and i agree with that but is
that singularly disqualifying
do i think that people fewer people
would be dead if donald trump were not
president
right now i have serious doubts
considering the vast majority of people
who have died in the united states died
in blue states where nobody supports
trump
okay so that that that is the media lie
i mean i got some texts from people in
the media like i saw your video
and it was good for what it was but you
didn't pay attention to code i was like
because
if you are asking me to differentiate
between the candidates you can't give me
an issue where everybody is basically
the same okay that happens to be the
case when it comes to covid
and the media myth notwithstanding
trump's actions are
identical to the actions that joe biden
would have taken
and yet this is the democratic narrative
and the media will continue to play that
self-pleasuring media refusing to
acknowledge the reality of the statement
i just made even though they know that
it's true i literally had phone
conversations
with people in the mainstream media they
acknowledged what i was saying was true
no one in europe has a handle on this
nobody in new york has a handle on this
no one in new jersey has a handle on
this nobody in massachusetts has a
handle on this basically the harder you
were hit the first time the less hard
hit you are being
the second time but that does not mean
that you got all of this right
in fact the states that have the lowest
transmission rates right now are the
states that got walloped the first time
including states like louisiana right a
red state with a blue governor and john
bel edwards
okay we'll get to trump and covet which
again is the media's backup plan they
don't want to talk about hunter biden
they want to talk about biden at all
so they just keep going back to trump
and covet which is predicated on on
a false idea about covid we'll get to
that in a second first
let us talk about the fact that malware
is out there if you've ever had your
computer hit with malware it is the
worst thing in the world i mean it just
ravages your computer ransomware people
locking up your files and then requiring
you to pay them
in order to free those files you need
something to protect your computer you
need pcmatic pcmatic is a next
generation antivirus designed to stop
modern threats like ransomware
independent testing from av test just
named pcmatic a top performer in the
cyber security industry
giving it the best performance award for
2019. only pcmatic has american research
development and support
pcmatic's competition is foreign made
often in countries where malware
originates
pcmatic blocks annoying and malicious
ads for hassle-free web browsing it
makes your computer faster and more
reliable even
after years of use pcmatic is just 50
bucks for five devices for one year with
a full
30-day money-back guarantee if you act
now pcmatic has offered my listeners a
free month of security protection with
the annual
purchase with the purchase of an annual
license if you're not protecting
yourself against malware it's a big
mistake you think it's not going to
affect you then it hits you
and boom your life is basically ruined
for at least a week and maybe longer to
access this offer go to pcmatic.com
ben again to get that world-class
security that keeps your computer
running great go to pcmatic.com
ben okay so again the media have fallen
back on the covet narrative
right because in the end they can't talk
about the economy
trump's economy was good they can't talk
about foreign policy trump's foreign
policy was good
they can talk about two things trump's
rhetoric and covet
and they can't really talk about covet
so instead what they like to do is talk
about trump's rhetoric oncovit because
again the policy trump has pursued
is precisely the same as the policies
that are now being pursued by everybody
across europe
trump's refusal to take top down control
i think of as an asset
he didn't nationalize american industry
he didn't nationalize the vaccine
production process
donald trump did not assert massive
top-down control over every area of the
united states
i'm seeing members of the media lament
and we're not like china right so
what you're saying is that you would
like the president of the united states
to weld people in their homes
if they have covet you would like to see
forcible quarantine
if people have covet just say it out
loud if that's what you want but joe
biden has not even
suggested that that is his policy and
when people say testing and tracing is
gonna fix this
not when you got community spread with
hundreds of thousands of people it ain't
you could have locked everybody down i
suppose and force them to stay in their
homes for months on end
but nobody in europe has done that and
the spread continues in europe
we're gonna have to learn to live with
the virus until a vaccine is developed
and even after a vaccine is developed it
is possible we'll have to learn to live
with the virus because again we don't
know the efficacy of the vaccine when
tried over a wide
range of human beings at that point
people are gonna have to go back to
normal and take their chances
everybody acknowledges this if they are
rational about this but
the media have crafted a narrative the
narrative is trump killed 200 000 people
and also that once trump is gone he's
like
a devilish meismatic evil once trump
goes all bad things in the universe
subside
this is how you know that the politics
has turned into paganism for so many
people
when barack obama left office and donald
trump took office i didn't think that
all bad things in the universe had
stopped
donald trump is a person he does things
some of them i like some of them i don't
but for democrats because they have so
much invested in politics because
so little is is play i mean honestly i
do think there's a religious aspect to
this because
religion seeks an outlet and if you're
not a religious person you seek that
outlet
in faith in the state faith in the
collective faith in political actors
you end up saying wildly paganistic
things about
politics and so this is the democratic
narrative donald trump if removed from
office
everything is justified removing the
devil right anything that you can do to
stop the devil you do
that means you don't report it means
that you say false things it means you
promote false narratives
all of that is okay because you're
stopping the devil and once the devil is
gone
then utopia reigns once once donald
trump satan is gone
then the sun breaks through the clouds
coveted magically dissipates
the economy starts to boom again racial
tolerance
is flowing across the land like milk and
honey if you believe any of this you're
a sucker
you're an absolute sucker but this is
what the media and democrats want you to
believe
we'll get to that false paganistic
narrative in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that i've
been spending a lot of time at home and
let me tell you something
i love the fact that i am sleeping on
bowling brand sheets at my house so when
i go on the road very often i don't have
the bowl and brand sheets and i just
sleep like crap
right now the only reason i'm not
sleeping is because my baby is teething
and getting me up in the middle of the
night but that just means it's even more
important that when i get back on my bed
i got those bull and branch sheets
on the bed bowling branch sheets they're
the softest most comfortable pure
organic cotton sheets
on earth bowling branches rain fed
pesticide free carries the highest
organic certification
which is why it is so soft and because
they work with family-owned mills all
over the world to expertly weave every
set of bowl and brand sheets with the
highest level of craftsmanship it is
quality
you can feel the moment you open that
magical box that is why three former
us presidents and millions of americans
use bull and branch sheets and since
they sell direct to you
bowling brand sheets start at just 160
bucks their thousand dollar quality for
a fraction of the price
plus you can sleep on them for a full
month risk free right now you'll get 50
bucks off any sheet set at bull and
branch dot com
with promo code ben shapiro spelled
b-o-l-l and branch dot com
promo code ben shapiro for 50 bucks off
bullanbranch.com
promo code ben shapiro restrictions may
apply c bullanbranch.com
for details okay we'll get to more in
just one second first
you may have noticed 2020 has been nuts
man statues toppled coupled with radical
riding and looting in american cities
it can feel at times like america is
coming apart well that's because it is
but it's not coming apart just because
of politics it's coming apart because
there's a difference in vision for the
country this is what my book how to
destroy america in three easy steps
is all about a uh a top new york times
bestseller it has sold hundreds of
thousands of copies already
how to destroy america in three easy
steps really does trace the founding
ideology of the united states the
history of the united states i get
questions a lot from parents
grandparents how do i educate people on
what america is all about
this is that book how to destroy america
in three easy steps is really about how
to build america in three easy steps
philosophy
culture history what is the philosophy
of the united states the founding
philosophy what is the culture of the
united states a culture
of adventure and entrepreneurialism a
culture of tolerance for other people's
rights
what is the history of the united states
a glorious history pockmarked by evil
right that is what this book is about
and it's about people who wish to
misappropriate all of that philosophy
culture and history in order to destroy
the country disintegrationists go pick
up the book right now how to destroy
america in three easy steps it's a
massive bestseller you should own a copy
you should make sure that your kids read
it uh it is it is not a partisan book
it is a book that is about bigger ideas
than simple partisanship meanwhile as
with everything in 2020 there's been a
lot of drama with the presidential
debates but
we are ready for the next final debate
this thursday join us at 8 45 pm eastern
5 45 pm pacific for an all new episode
of daily wire backstage you can watch
the debate with us get our immediate
live reaction
to this major political event even
better join daily where right now as an
insider or all access member get 20
with code debate 20 off you can watch
all the debate coverage
live on our apple tv or roku app what do
members get well i'm glad you asked bob
members get our articles had free access
to all of our live broadcasts and show
library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show exclusive reader's past content
available only
to daily wire members if you're
considering an all access membership you
get to join us on all access live every
night for online
live stream discussions you also get not
one but you count them to you
leftist yours tumblers with your
membership as well as early sometimes
exclusive access to new daily wire
products so
watch the debate with us on
dailywire.com youtube and facebook get
off your daily wire membership with code
debate when you sign up today you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
the narrative that has been crafted by
democrats with regard to
the trump administration is that once
trump goes everything goes back to
normal
and so just ignore everything bad that's
happening in pursuit of the devil you
can do anything now
there's a famous scene in one of my
favorite plays movies
uh a a man for all seasons about sir
thomas more
in which he has a son-in-law named roper
and thomas moore
is being basically blackmailed by a guy
named richard rich
played the movie by john hurt he's being
blackmailed with the threat that he's
going to tell the king
that thomas moore does not approve of
his
of his divorce and remarriage and thomas
moore is talking to his son-in-law roper
and roper says you should arrest that
man and thomas morris is on what charge
and he says well make up the charge just
arrest him he's going to get you killed
and thomas moore says you'd cut down the
law to go after the devil and roper says
i would cut down the law to go after the
devil i cut down every law in england to
go after the devil and thomas more says
oh you would
what happens when all the laws are down
and the devil turns around on you
where are you going to hide then and
that is what is happening in the united
states in pursuit of donald trump
every institution has been militarized
in pursuit of donald trump every truth
has been thrown out in pursuit of donald
trump everybody has decided that the
rules no longer apply because when
you're going after the devil the entire
forest of laws
the entire forest of fact and
objectivity all of it has to go away
the media doesn't have to do its job
because trump has to leave office we can
tell overt lies about covet policy
because trump has to leave office
you can simply ignore big and important
corruption narratives you don't have to
do your job as a journalist because
trump has to leave office so what
happens when
when a republican takes power again
let's say that trump wins reelection
how are all these journalists going to
maintain their credibility they've
destroyed their credibility
how are democrats going to maintain
their credibility they've destroyed
their credibility
the institutional collapsing that
collapses we see all around us
the attempts to rip into everything from
the police
to to corporations the the attempt to
twist everything in pursuit of donald
trump means
that trust in america is at an all-time
low and it's going to get lower not
higher in the future because the
institutional trust that we have in all
of our institutions
has basically been destroyed it has not
been destroyed by trump right trump has
said things
about our institutions that i've
disagreed with and i think are bad but
it is the democrats
willingness to actually use those
institutions as brickbats
against trump that means that people no
longer trust the institutions
okay so in pursuit of this narrative
democrats are willing to say anything
how bad is this elizabeth warren
yesterday she said something that many
democrats have said
she was campaigning for joe biden was
the senator from massachusetts
and i i know elizabeth warren a little
bit i met her a little interacted a
little bit with her at harvard law
school she's too smart for this but
again this has become a pagan religion
elizabeth warren says that donald trump
threatens all human life on the planet
all human life on the planet he's satan
and so if he is satan you can do
whatever you want in order to target him
here's elizabeth warren laying that out
he not only hasn't made things better he
has actively
made them worse he withdraws from the cl
the paris climate accord
he's put a coal lobbyist
in charge of the environmental
protection agency what could possibly go
wrong
he has opened up for offshore drilling
and he has said yes to the oil companies
they can drill
in the arctic national wildlife preserve
donald trump threatens the existence
of human life of all life on this planet
okay that's insane i'm sorry that's just
totally crazy
that's crazy the existence of all human
so you're telling me that by drilling an
anwar
that all human life is threatened that's
been like a hot issue since i was in
college in 2000
20 years ago you're telling me that if
the climate warms
approximately four degrees fahrenheit
over the course of the next century that
it threatens all light not just human
life
all life on this planet according to
elizabeth warren that that is her case
hey that's paganistic nonsense it truly
is and that has been carried over to
covid where without any evidence
whatsoever the media have suggested that
if a democrat were in charge two hundred
thousand people wouldn't be dead
let's be very clear about this if
hillary clinton had been president in
2020 you know how many people would be
dead
probably about the same number as our
debt under donald trump
because nobody knows what to do with
this thing nobody knows what to do with
this thing
this bizarre idea that donald trump is
responsible for people losing their
lives through his coveted policy is
idiotic
so what they've decided to focus on is
the only point of real contra
distinction
between democrats and republicans on
covet and that is the rhetoric and this
is where trump really has failed he has
stepped on rake after rake after right
when it comes to covet
in the last two weeks of an election you
know it's a really bad strategy going to
war
with anthony fauci that is a bad
strategy it's what democrats have been
begging for for months
because again democrats can't point to
anything that trump has quote unquote
done in terms of policy
that really has hurt the country in
terms of covet worse than any place else
donald trump is not responsible for the
massive spike we are now seeing in case
numbers in europe
he is not responsible for the fact that
blue states did much worse than red
states in the early going
and that would be on andrew cuomo who's
being touted at the dnc
as captain covet handler okay but so
they focus in instead on the point of
distinction which again it always comes
down to trump's rhetoric if you just
stripped trump's rhetoric from the trump
administration the democrats are
stripped of virtually every talking
point so it always comes down to trump's
rhetoric so since the beginning of covid
they've been trying to drive a wedge
between trump and fauci
very early on foucher refused it and
trump refused it well now fouchy's been
doing more and more interviews
he was on the cover of intouch magazine
which again i don't understand how you
can perceive yourself as a serious
public health official and be posing for
photo shoots within touch magazine it's
just
i i gotta say i'm not a huge fouchy fan
i've said that i think fauci is doing
his best under trying circumstances
i think that he has evolved with new
information i think that we only see
snippets of him
right he was four lockdowns then he was
against lockdown to his anti-mass then
he was format but okay
like everybody's moving with the new
evidence as it comes out well faucet did
an interview on 60 minutes
in which he got very angry that donald
trump had used him in an
ad which again was not illegitimate
fouch is a trusted public figure he said
we've done the best that we can we've
done more than anybody else could have
and trump used that in an ad
okay well he's the president you work
for him right you're in the executive
branch so who the hell do you think you
work for really
right so that was illegitimate it was
fauci uh
instead decided on 60 minutes to go out
and appear so there was a private
campaign phone call
that has now been leaked right so i
guess that since it's been leaked we
can't pay attention to it according to
the media that's the way this works
right it's unauthorized leakage
i don't see twitter taking any of this
down so trump on this phone call ripped
into fauci
and and called him an idiot now
is this a smart campaign strategy of
course not because fauci
has again become the repository of the
anti-trump sentiment so ripping into
fauci
allows the democrats to play a game with
you which is fauci is
is captain science and trump is captain
anti-science and then trump plays right
into that right he'll go out as rallies
and he'll say
joe biden says listen to the science and
biden will be like yup
which is literally what happened the
other day trump said that at a rally he
said
you know biden will listen to fouchy and
biden just tweeted out yes that is a
rhetorical idiocy on the president's
part this is
this is where democrats are really
making their hay so this campaign phone
call has now become the big headline
here is trump calling vouching idiot on
a campaign phone call
people are tired of hearing fauci and
all these idiots these
these people these people that have
gotten it wrong found she's a nice guy
he's been here for 500 years he called
every one of them wrong
okay so there he was going after fouchy
uh then
he uh suggested that he was considered
firing fauci uh
he he said that he had considered firing
it but it would cause more of a
firestorm than just keeping him around
every time he goes on television there's
always a bomb
but there's a bigger bomb of your
firearm
okay and then trump tweeted against
fauci right he tweeted out dr tony fauci
says we don't allow him to do television
and yet i saw him last night on 60
minutes
he seems to get more air time than
anybody since the late great bob hope
all i ask of tony is that he make better
decisions he said no masks and let china
in
also bad arm which is just typical trump
right is that he threw a bad first pitch
and then he reiterated this
ps tony should stop wearing the
washington nationals masks for two
reasons
number one it is not up to the high
standards that he should be exposing
number two
it keeps reminding me that tony threw
out perhaps the worst first pitch in the
history of baseball
going to war with your health advisor on
covid like
two weeks from the election is that your
final election picture
is that your final election pitch so
democrats look for the point of
distinction the point of distinction is
that trump says things
and um and so trump decides to double
down on all of that
he decides to double down on that now
again it's he's not wrong when he says
the media have miscovered covet and so
trump at a rally
called cnn dumb bastards fact check
mostly true i mean here is trump going
after cnn
they're getting tired of the pandemic
aren't they getting tired of the thing
you turn on cnn that's all they cover
covet covert pendant cove at covent cove
and
you know why they're trying to talk
everybody out of voting people aren't
buying it cnn you dumb bastards they're
not
okay so are they really trying to talk
people out of voting no are they really
trying to talk people into the idea that
trump has killed tons of people from
covet of course that is what cnn's overt
goal is at this point
trump walking directly into that door is
not particularly smart strategy now
again i have serious doubts on whether
the trust the science crowd actually
trust the science
considering that you still have andrew
cuomo going out there and saying he
literally will not trust a vaccine if
trump says to take it
which again i'm not taking anything just
because trump says to take it i'll take
it because the scientific community says
to take it i don't even understand the
point of this the vaccine is not even
going to be greenlit until after the
election why are you sowing doubts about
a vaccine that is not going to be
greenlit until after we know who the
next president of the united states is
going to be but here was andrew cuomo
doing that here's party of science
andrew cuomo
i'm not that confident but my opinion
doesn't matter i don't believe the
american people are that confident
you're going to say to the american
people now here's a vaccine
it was new it was done quickly but trust
this federal administration and their
health administration that it's safe
uh and um we're not 100 sure of the
consequences
i think it's going to be a very
skeptical american public about taking
the vaccine and they should be so
remember the entire democratic party
infrastructure has been including kamala
harris has been sowing doubts about
taking a vaccine right so when you hear
about how people are getting people
killed from covet
the same party that said it was okay to
march in the streets millions strong
said it was okay to go to a funeral so
long as it was of a prominent leftist
the same party that suggests that
vaccines are bad
right now because they're being
developed under the trump administration
and those are the people who are
definitely going to protect you from
covet
it's all false narratives all the way
down all the way down
okay meanwhile there is a big piece of
election news coming out of the supreme
court
the supreme court john roberts is just a
terrible justice he is i'm sorry
he you know his he thinks that his sole
mandate is to somehow
preserve in some way the the legitimacy
of the court and his way of preserving
the legitimate legitimacy of the court
is to avoid quote-unquote controversy in
the here and now
as opposed to controversy in the later
he's constantly kicking the can down the
road so on the aca he will rewrite the
law
just as just so that the supreme court
is not required to strike down
a law that was very controversial he'll
rewrite it just to quote unquote
re-establish the institutional
legitimacy of the supreme court question
did it help answer no
john roberts is constantly doing this
kind of stuff so here's a perfect case
in point
yesterday the supreme court refused to
take
up a case to split 4-4 i'm taking up a
case
on pennsylvania voting so here's the
underlying fact pattern
in pennsylvania there is a a law on the
books
the law on the books is that you have to
vote by november 3rd
right november 3rd is not an arbitrary
deadline as andrew mccarthy points out
it is the election
it's a date fixed by congress for voting
across the country to take place
okay well under the constitution states
have a great deal of discretion
regarding the manner in which elections
are conducted
but that discretion is not limitless the
election is november 3rd
whatever time frame the states allow for
early voting whatever procedures they
prescribe
for authenticating legitimate mail and
ballots the voting has to be concluded
on november 3rd
the constitution states it is for
congress to determine the time of
choosing the electors
in modern parliaments for conducting in
each state the presidential election
the states don't have authority to alter
that date okay in pennsylvania they just
altered the date
the pennsylvania supreme court says andy
mccarthy from national review is
enmeshed in politics its members are
elected not appointed for 10-year terms
a few weeks back in a 4-3 ruling along
partisan lines with democrats in the
majority
the court nullified the mandate duly
enacted by the state's legislature that
mail-in ballots
must be received in the office of the
county board of elections no later than
8 o'clock p.m
on the day of the primary or election
you know that that
law makes perfect sense right because
what you would like to do is start
counting
so everything has to be received by a
certain date this is something by the
way that the post office
actually warned about months ago they
put out an actual notice to states
across the country saying
you know guys you really should change
your laws so the final date on which
people can send their mail
for an election gives enough time for us
to deliver that mail such that the thing
can be received by the date of the
election
the constitution and federal law as the
supreme court has observed vests
discretion to set election rules in the
state legislatures not state courts
and as even the pennsylvania court
conceded it was within the legitimate
power of the state's general assembly to
set this deadline
there was no ambiguity about it or any
legal infirmity right if you wanted your
ballot counted it had to be received by
november 3rd
yet the court's democratic judges
dictated a three-day extension
of the lawful deadline for counting
mail-in ballots the vehicle for this act
of willful usurpation was a lawsuit
brought by surprise the pennsylvania
democratic party
the state court's majority invoked a
hurl at the wall and see what sticks
combination of rationales
said to flow from covet national natural
disasters emergency situations
a loopy construction of the state
constitution's free and equal elections
clause
theorizing that since the virus does not
affect all people the same way
provisions the legislature makes to deal
with it somehow render elections
unfair and unequal so what does this
actually do what does the court ruling
do the court effectively ruled that you
can vote after election day
the pennsylvania court requires election
officials to presume that any ballot
received by its extended deadline now
november 6th
must be counted even if it lacks
postmarked proof it was mailed on or
before november 3rd
so you could see an election in which
the entire thing comes down to
pennsylvania in fact this is quite easy
to see because pennsylvania's a
battleground state right you could see
an election in which trump replicates
all the states that he won except for
michigan and wisconsin and now he needs
to win pennsylvania and joe biden needs
to win pennsylvania and the entire
election rests on pennsylvania
and it's november 3rd and we don't know
the results right november third
happens and it's a very tight election
in pennsylvania again right now
that election is within three to four
points right it's close to margin of
error
and you now have a pennsylvania law that
says that
if no the day after the election right
november 4th now
everybody looks at the tv they recognize
it comes down to pennsylvania
and everybody rushes to their mailbox
and sends in their ballot people who
didn't vote they rushed to their mailbox
and now they send in their ballot
according to pennsylvania state supreme
court those will be counted if received
by november 6th whether or not they are
postmarked late
even if it lacks postmark proof it was
mailed on or before november 3rd
as andy mccarthy said in effect it
greenlights voting after election day
even as the national media is reporting
the results of a contest that is
supposed to be over
for those reasons the state's republican
party asked the supreme court to stay
the court's ruling
to the extent it permits voting after
election day
the supreme court adheres to a so-called
purcell principle arising
out of its 2006 ruling in purcell versus
gonzales the courts must not change the
rules for an election late in the game
purcell is now being flouted not just in
pennsylvania in wisconsin judge william
conley an obama appointee on the federal
district court
presumed to rewrite a number of state
law election related deadlines including
extending the deadline for
counting absentee ballots until november
9th in his wisdom judge conley
caveat of the ballots should only be
counted if they are mailed in by
election day november 3rd which sounds
fine in theory
but there's going to be a lot of dispute
about when ballots were mailed right
you're going to say i dropped it off
at the post office i dropped it into
mailbox november 3rd it wasn't
postmarked until november 4th
so did i mail it in on time so the
supreme court
could have intervened here the supreme
court could have done something here
okay well in april the high court
intervened in a similar wisconsin case
judge conley hadn't just extended by a
week after election day the deadline for
mail and ballots to be received
by state election officials he had
ordered that votes be counted even if
they were mailed after election day and
the supreme court stayed conley's order
all four liberal block justice including
now deceased rbg dissented from the
unsigned opinion by a five justice
majority
the majority concluded that to permit
people to keep voting after election day
would gravely affect the integrity of
the election process
but the opinion took pain to emphasize
it was forbidding the counting of
post-election mail and ballots because
conley had ordered it unilaterally
i either had been no request for that
relief which suggested if a party had
asked for it the court might have
approved post-election day voting
which is insane so now the court is is
essentially saying that they are going
to put off decisions on whether or not
to count ballots until after election
day itself
so here's how this is going to go let's
say that it does come down to what we're
talking about it comes down to
pennsylvania
it comes down to states that have
extended their voting deadlines after
election day
which is crazy by the way and now you
have a ninth justice on the supreme
court amy coney baird who's going to be
confirmed this week or early next
and now democrats proclaim that a
five-seat majority on the supreme court
with amy coney barrett and the majority
is illegitimate because amy coney
barrett was rammed through
i mean the possibilities here are
devastating and if you're talking about
the legitimacy of the supreme court
if that's john roberts chief concern i
cannot think of anything more calibrated
to undermine that legitimacy than what
the supreme court is doing
right here okay meanwhile the debate is
happening final debate between trump and
biden is happening that is happening on
thursday night
well now new rules have been set
according to the new york times
president trump and
joseph biden will be muted during the
portions of thursday's final
presidential debate
an effort by the organizers to avoid the
unruly spectacle that played out at the
candidate's first meeting in cleveland
last month now here's the thing i don't
think that you should mute the mics
i actually don't think you should mute
the mics the reason is if you're a
democrat i'm confused why you'd want to
mute the mics
if you look at the polls what you see is
that trump's performance in the last
debate killed him
it was terrible for him he started
dumping in the polls immediately after
that before he even got coveted
by polling data so why exactly would you
want to mute the mics okay so fine
they're muting the mics
as in the first debate each candidate
will be allotted two minutes of speaking
time to initially answer the moderator's
questions
under a plan announced on monday the
opponent's mike will be turned off
during that period
in an attempt to ensure an uninterrupted
response trump said he wasn't happy
about it
trump said i'll participate i just think
it's very unfair i'll participate but
it's very unfair they changed the topics
it's very unfair that again we have an
anchor who is totally biased
the commission acknowledged both
campaigns might be dissatisfied with the
new rules one
might think they go too far one might
think they don't go far enough
the thursday debate is the final meeting
of the of the candidates there were
supposed to be three debates the second
one
got cancelled because the debate
commission unilaterally suggested that
trump's covet forbade it even though
there was no medical information that
suggested
that this was the case meanwhile
bill stephen trump's campaign manager he
claimed that the nonpartisan commission
he called the biden debate commission
had promised that the national debate
would be about foreign policy and asked
for to discard the six subjects
announced last week by the moderator
kristen welker those topics are fighting
kovid american families race in america
climate change national security and
leadership
you can see why the uh the trump
administration would like to talk about
foreign policy which is
a big bright spot for them as opposed to
more conversation about racism and is
true
i mean is trump a white supremacist and
all this garbage again
again okay so biden's people are of
course very happy with the rule changes
so once again it'll be trump
versus the moderator for sure
now final note here it turns out that
when people actually look at policy when
they look
when people look at policy when they
look beyond the personalities of the
candidates
it turns out that democratic policies
are just not that popular polls show
this
polls show that democrats may be more
popular than republicans but that is a
personality question
that is based on social disapproval it
is not based on
actual policy 56 of americans according
to gallup say they are better off now
than they were four years ago a
plurality
support republican policies over
democratic policies this culminated
yesterday in 50 cent
the rapper slash actor television
producer
tweeting out a graphic of the top tax
rates by state
this is according to i believe fox
business
uh the the it showed top tax rates by
states under the biden tax plan
california would have a top tax rate of
62.6 percent
new jersey would have a 60 top tax rate
new york state would have a 58
top tax rate new york city would have a
62 percent top tax rate as according to
the tax foundation
and that is because of an increase in
social security tax as well as an
increase in personal income tax for
people at the top tax bracket 50 cent
tweeted out
what the f vote for trump i'm out f new
york the knicks never win anyway
i don't care trump doesn't like black
people 62 are you out of effing mind
so first of all it's not true that trump
doesn't like black people but it turns
out that democratic policies are wildly
unpopular so here is the good news if
you're a republican and you're deeply
worried about the outcome of this
election
as you should be if joe biden is elected
president and if the democrats take the
senate right now
pollsters suggest there's about a 75
shot that democrats take the senate
there's no doubt democrats will promptly
go too far pass a bunch of crappy policy
and there will be a reaction to it in
two years which means that what our real
fear should be is them wrecking the
system and adding seats to the senate
and completely changing the constituency
of the supreme court institutional
changes
that outlast the temporary if however
democrats push too far
on the bizarre thought that this is not
about trump they made the entire
election about trump
so if trump is ousted and then they say
well really it wasn't a referendum on
trump it was a referendum on how much
people love high taxes
they will go for it they will go for
broke and the reaction will be exactly
50 cent's reaction
and the pendulum will swing back the
other way okay
we'll be back here later today for two
additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nico geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
the director of national intelligence
confirms that the hunter biden emails
are
real a cnn analyst gets caught with his
pants down
and more evidence of voter fraud crops
up in kentucky
check it out on the michael knowles show